[Music]
so do you guys think that if you like
the rainbow pattern it's automatically
like that automatically means that you
are in the LGBTQ I knew you were gonna
ask I was in fifth grade I remember
moving to from Virginia to San Diego and
we had a class project where we all had
to color like a [ __ ] picture of a
castle or some [ __ ] and I did it
completely rainbow cuz I just thought it
looks sick I know is gay and then my and
then and then my teacher was like oh
teacher remove you from all the other
boys no no she was she was just like oh
okay
even way back then in those days it was
like that yes she knew about it way back
it's not that far back guys but it's
only like 30 years ago okay so when I
was a kid I had no idea and no one ever
mentioned it like know it like it wasn't
a thing like I remember that was this
one there were a couple people actually
mainly girls that they loved rainbow
everything Rainbow Brite rose and Frank
or Lisa Frank Frank and Frank
she used to close her eyes and think of
what rainbows look like I remember like
just rainbow was just fun and bright and
Clips like I mean not that it's not it
still just wasn't branded okay it wasn't
branded like that so anyway well now in
today's close culture it's it makes me
be the Hawaii though you know that's the
Hawaiian license plate Oh Joe rainbow
but I have those thoughts like whenever
I wear it cuz I love rainbow anything so
whenever I work like I have some rainbow
socks and then I'll wear it cuz it just
looks cool and I'm like people they
think I'm gay okay when you're the man I
love this lesbian oh but you know what I
feel like there's always leniency for
when ladies do it for sure yeah you guys
can get away with it and nobody like
they may ask but they don't assume that
you are just because like women I use it
a lot more vocal about the support of
groups and things like that and you guys
if we even if we are in support of it we
can't wear certain things because it's
automatically a swing you don't support
lucky charms I never thought
anything I was like I'm gonna chase the
rainbow because there's a pot of gold at
the end of that skills but yeah I get it
now but traditionally guys didn't
normally wear like rainbows was a girl
thing when I was growing up Ellie kids
are girls Care Bears had this camera
every cartoon I watched I goddamn
rainbows in it every single one so I
thought rainbows were the sickest [ __ ]
and I still do yeah they're still pretty
dope but there was this fifteen year old
girl from Kentucky who goes to this
Christian school oh and she got expelled
after her birthday like so okay I can
relate I can relate to getting stuff
from I hold on hold on first let me tell
you so her mom posted this photo on her
own Facebook I like her so nurses Kalish
like a cake and so KK was wearing you
know as you can see a rainbow uh sweater
and her her cake is rainbow that would
spawn actually because of this photo
being posted on her mom's social media
this girl got kicked out of school they
were like your two day to go to our
school
right so they ended up saying this this
is a doll so that's the thing she isn't
and the cake that they ordered they even
showed her receipt they were like it we
just request requested it to be assorted
colors like it wasn't like we're trying
to we're not trying to make any
statement you know she's she's not gay
well she was God say yeah you can expel
her for that I mean you're not wrong
because the school has like their rules
and so that's the reason that's what
their that's what they are this I see is
that in the rulebook though they're like
you cannot like or display any sort of
rainbows so they're saying that it's uh
like there's even lifestyle like viola I
think that's illegal you can't say you
can't come to the school cuz you're gay
so they're saying that there's
violations of the Student Code of
Conduct that's what they're saying
it's cuz it's a private group or
whatever privates private like like if
we had a private club and and we're like
no girls allowed like that's still
allowed until we'd like the school said
they said whitfill Academy is a
Christian based school with a 43-year
history of
hating students in the learning
environment informed by our shared
Christian values all parents who enroll
their children in a private school know
upfront that we asked the students to
adhere to a lifestyle warmed by our
Christian beliefs so that's what they're
standing by and the I guess publicly
like for everyone else reading into the
story it's like what like just because
she had a rainbow sweater on and her
cake is rainbow that's ridiculous I just
see Aloha spirit
like she has a lot of law hospital they
assumed that she was lesbian but then
because of law they can't call her out
and ask is she lesbian or gay so then
they just made they're like oh this is
scary she probably is a lesbian so it's
like whistle for gay support yeah so
then because if you flat out like just
I'm thinking about this legally right so
if you flat out ask her family and then
they're like no and then you get into
that weird area law suits and weird
things can start you know what the ended
of doing once that was posted in the
schools believing that she was gay they
started they were citing a book called
gay girl good god which was given to her
by a guidance counselor after the photos
were shared so they already just assumed
she was super gay because of it because
they saw the photo they're like oh my
god we got to do something she's so gay
the world is so afraid of homosexuality
like if it doesn't directly affect you
why do I care of it like of my daughter
decided she wanted to I just don't I
don't care who you [ __ ] it right it has
never bothered me how you get down and I
don't think a man is any less masculine
well I don't think he's any less of a
man because he's gay
it's how he treats his man yeah yeah
sweet that man like a man that is if we
opened the door for that man yeah put
him on the walk on the inside or not
sidewalk I wonder like I think cuz he's
like the most relationship you see a guy
in a guy like one of us
like a little more effeminate than
another guy one of their like two hard
guys like what's up [ __ ] you just saw
[ __ ] right that's what happened if
indeed no that's what happened to Vin
Diesel in the rock dude couldn't make it
work it couldn't make it work I'm gonna
[ __ ] you didn't know I'm gonna [ __ ] you
tonight and then they had the wrath of
the season gets [ __ ] know what
happened I'm so into it because I don't
know much about that part of it so so um
I went to this seminar and like it's
like a life type seminar right and they
help you like with the blueprint of your
life and [ __ ] and one of the segments
they talk about relationships and a good
relationship is something that has
polarity which is the masculine with the
feminine so these guys that you're
talking about can both be masculine on
the outside but one of them is a little
bit more on the feminine yes always
there's always that it's always that so
back to KK here
she okay yeah she um apparently got
kicked out or expelled for more than
just this according to the school she
had been doing a lot of numerous rainbow
unicorn
she had a rainbow Network she's like a
little girl she had more than one
birthday which is that's you know you
don't do more than one birthday party
okay so the other violations were that
she was cutting class and she got caught
with a jewel pod somehow like so she was
vaping and damn Christian Bay person
yeah so they're saying like you know
she's being punished for lifestyle
violations but this family ended up
saying now that they are suing hell yeah
like how the schools like that rainbow
sweater just pushed us over the edge no
the best [ __ ] is like is like they're
like okay get rid of her she's gay and
then they're like wait she's not getting
no [ __ ] okay let's see ah it's like what
my buddy got pulled over but I caught
one time because they cop he was driving
a carpool lane and his wife is so
[ __ ] small ha ha ha the cop thought
he was driving like single rider and
then he cop walks up he's like and he's
like hey let me see your license
registration and then the guys like one
away what - what for what's going on and
the guys like yeah you're driving
erratic look in prize money like
you see them walk back to the front of
car he's going to share what his tags
are actually up-to-date there's got to
be something I can find you yet tire
pressures low sir like I can't believe
she's not gay what are we gonna do okay
what can we make her kiss a boy we can't
do that okay
jewel pod we got a dual pol grab the
expelled from school for such a jewel
bow no but for them they're like she's
done all these horrible things and we
gave her a chance after chance this this
is not acceptable this is so crazy that
I almost like there's no way this is
real I know it sounds crazy this is a
blessing for the little girl though
honestly like please explain from this
[ __ ] dumbass school I went to a
Christian school daddy end up coming out
with a payout now they're suing the
group I pushed over that pushed the
Christian school over the edge for me
was my hair really oh my lord
was it kay it was just like yeah it was
super gay
the hair was too gay god damn it it was
rainbow how was it how was your real
life I had I had I had a I had two bangs
like this coming down oh my [ __ ] god
right you were that guy yeah I had two
bangs on the side and in the principal
came up to me and said we're not gonna
have you come back next semester that's
too radical he said because of your hair
he that song he said it was just
lifestyle choices
have you ever seen some of some of these
like my dad in the 70s like some
pictures I see a van I'm like this guy
wasn't gay like are you kidding me
because there's some of the pants they
wore the shirts look at open chested
[ __ ] I guarantee you these cats who run
this school you're good they got
pictures of them 30 years ago with those
[ __ ] tiny boy shorts on and [ __ ] and
that's worse than any [ __ ] rainbow
birth and the way they hold their best
friends to like this right
just me man's
but that's the reason why they retaliate
because it's projection they're insecure
because at one point maybe the art
getting missed it they're afraid of
being that's an episode episode there's
a one of the James Bond it was with Sean
Connery I forget which one it was but he
had like a rapper piece yeah oh yeah the
one we used poolside yeah yeah one piece
I was just like that was the thing and
it had like looked wow oh boy
it also had this thing around his neck
so if you hold it all up like a halter
top yeah you know it was illegal back in
a day for dudes to show their nipples
that's why you'll see like guys at the
beach just wearing one piece it's
[ __ ] that's weird masculinity was
still trying to get its [ __ ] together I
don't care I got a six pack seven when I
get a six pack I'm showing these titties
you don't see these nipples so what
you're gonna have a six pack entity I
make us bad booze on me going away fast
as everything goes man man boobs just be
kind of hanging around seen if anybody
got any spare change
[Music]